[Music]
flipping your fins you don't get too far
legs are required for jumping dancing I
literally do not understand how this is
all happening
it's giving me chills thinking about it
the character of Ariel is a girl who
feels displaced
she wants something more and you feel
that in every poor palette the
outpouring when we release that teaser
and just kid after kid you're like me
the world is so excited to see this role
I'm really excited for that moment to
finally happen
we are upset every day and there's
always a beautiful very soft Melody that
she's just humming along to I never said
anything I never wanted her to stop just
to feel Hallie be that little mermaid I
think we're gonna feel that for a long
time
I'm just so excited for people to see
The Little Mermaid Ariel has drive and
passion and gumption
is one of the most memorable and
incredible experiences of this job so
talented she's amazing in my heart my
five-year-old little self she could have
seen me now I think she would just be
blown away
[Music]